je crois qu'il faut le reconnaître on
est dans une période un peu bizarre en
ce moment avec cette histoire de kovy de
confinement pas confinement pas confiné
couvre-feu campagne on travaille souvent
de chez nous le télétravail en tout cas
est vraiment encourager ça modifie un
petit peu à la façon de bosser et
justement dans ce cadre là on a un tout
nouveau produit qui nous est présenté
par samsung c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui fait en collaboration avec samsung
pour vous présenter justement ce produit
là qui s'appelle le smart money doréus
marc molitor
il est vachement intéressant parce qu'il
répond vraiment cette problématique est
dans l'air du temps qui est resté chez
soi travailler de chez soi se divertir
de chez soi aller au cinéma chez soi
faire tout chez soi c'est vraiment le
problème qu'on a avec cette crise
actuelle on fait tous chez soi alors il
faut s'équiper il faut du bon matos pour
pouvoir bosser correctement
c'est compliqué de pouvoir emmener tout
ce qu'on a à son bureau à son travail et
avoir du matériel de qualité à la maison
et justement l'idée de smart monitor
c'est que vous avez un tout-en-un en
quelque sorte pour avoir du matériel qui
vous servira aussi bien pour travailler
mais également pour du divertissement
enfin il vous servira pour énormément de
choses et c'est un outil qui est
extrêmement pratique et que je suis très
content en tout cas pouvoir tester pour
vous présenter aujourd'hui alors je tout
expliqué il est hyper intéressant dans
plein de domaines que ce soit déjà ne
serait ce que comme ça avec la petite
télécommande voyez pour venir naviguer
on peut avoir accès à des films on peut
avoir accès à des séries mais on peut
également l'utiliser
et bien pour venir travailler grâce à la
petite télécommande enfin il ya plein de
choses à raconter tout ça vraiment hypra
cool donc voilà aujourd'hui on se parle
du smac moniteur de samsung
[Musique]
avant de rentrer dans l'uzège vraiment
professionnel où on va vraiment
recentrer sur l' usage ordinateur
productivité même productivité familiale
clairement on va se concentrer sur le
côté divertissement côté un petit peu
léger ça ça m'intéresse
avant de parler du côté divertissement
et un petit peu plus léger on a parlé du
matériel le smart monitor en fait il ya
plusieurs configurations il ya plusieurs
tailles d'écran aussi c'est la grande
taille d'écran c'est un 32 pouces il est
quand même vraiment aidants et à la foi
et à la fois et c'est ce qui m'intéresse
mais vraiment très très faim ce qui fait
que vous le caler mais très facilement
dans un coin de votre bureau vous mettez
tout au fond du bureau si vous souhaitez
vous avez un grand dégagement
vous avez un petit pied qui au final va
pas venir prendre trop de place
la toute première chose qu'il faut
savoir est ce qu'il a un petit capteur
de lumière pour venir adapter la
luminosité de l'écran par rapport à la
lumière ambiante je trouve qu'en fait le
smart monitor c'est un mix qui est assez
intelligente entre la télé connectée
telle qu'on peut la connaître chez
samsung avec tyson c'est le logiciel que
vous et pouvoir retrouver sur vos télés
de samsung donc là vous avez dû tyson
il est donc à mi chemin entre une télé
connectée et entre un moniteur
d'ordinateur taux pourrait imaginer
façon un peu plus classiquement vous
avez néanmoins cette télécommande de
narc un peu comme une télécommande de
télé qui en fait très très très
intuitive à pouvoir venir utiliser vous
avez un petit bouton pour venir là lui
bel éteindre un bouton pour venir avoir
retracé en local notamment bixby pouvait
venir naviguer ici est validée au centre
le bouton retour le bouton maison le
bouton lecture contrôle de volume
contrôle de shia poser des petits
raccourcis netflix prennent vidéo et
opte pour le web parce que ouais et ça
c'est aussi intéressant vous avez un
navigateur web ici directement intégré
la toute première chasse pourrait venir
vous connecter sur votre moniteur depuis
votre smartphone je vous montre comment
ça marche ici je vous prends l'exemple
sur un iphone mais pourrait le faire
bien évidemment très facilement sur un
smartphone de samsung c'est notamment
grâce à l'application smart singh qui
vous permet de connecter tous les objets
de l'écosystème samsung ici dans mon
iphone je vais juste aller hop is here
copies d'écran il reconnaît mon samsung
m 7
la suite me faire ce que je veux je peux
être dans google photos je peux venir me
mettre des photos tout simplement voilà
c'est très simple c'est hyper intuitive
je peux venir naviguer enfin moi je peux
faire vraiment du mirroring depuis mon
smartphone grâce à airplay de 2 apple
vous pouvez venir faire ça donc ça c'est
vraiment vraiment très très chouette et
après vous faites tous directement
depuis votre télécommande si vous avez
c'est l'expérience d'été
déconnectée de samsung c'est vraiment
vraiment sensiblement la même chose vous
allez pouvoir à choisir ici vos
applications préférées l'on va retrouver
bien évidemment netflix j'ai les films
et séries bon j'ai tout mon côté là de
netflix qui est ici je renifle exprime
vidéo j'ai apple tv j'ai ocs bon canal
rakuten joue pas un peu l'histoire
youtube galerie pour voir aussi mes
photos je rmc sport spotify molotov tv
disney + et jeux permettent beaucoup
plus
ensuite je vais pouvoir venir retrouver
tout mon catalogue d'applications ici
j'ai tout par thématique j'ai donc le
jeu le sport mode de vie informations
same enfin bref j'ai énormément
d'applications que je veux pouvoir dire
utiliser ici pour la maison même des
applications de catch je vous montre
quand même quelques petits paramètres ça
c'est vraiment ce qui va être
intéressant vous avez des paramètres
d'image que vous pouvez retrouver ici
mode stand armes naturelles mode cinéma
vous pensez en filmmaker mode si vous
voulez vous avez également la même chose
sur le son standard adaptatif amplifié
or c'est pour l'expérience audio alors
ici l'expérience audio elle est pas
complètement dingos ça marche bien vous
avez deux petits haut-parleurs 2 5 watts
jumeaux de jeu pour l activer en étant
connecter un périphérique externe si par
exemple je me teins brancher une console
dessus playstation ou une xbox peu
importe
grâce à du hdmi les sages de notre terre
les connectiques et bien je peux venir
avec fait mon objet ça c'est pas mal la
même chose ici j'ai un mode ultra
gamecube toujours pour le gaming mais
j'ai pas rien de brancher dessus donc
j'ai pas mode de protection va
protection des yeux ça c'est bien pour
qu'une protection contre la lumière
bleue et aussi contre les flics heures
c'est un peu l'effet qu'on peut voir au
niveau des os à dire fatiguer les yeux
l'âge ni le mode de protection bas c'est
comme être plus élevé ça vient rendre
l'image un peu plus jeunes de plus marc
au nez c'est pas extraordinaire et j'ai
même mon format d'image qui est
intéressant là je suis en 16/9 pourrait
bien mettre du 21 9e l'idée c'est que si
vous avez un jeu une application ou une
source externe ou ça viendra cros points
donnant l'image parce que l'on est sur
du 16/9 vous aurez une image qui sera
plus allongée à l'intérieur et si vous
avez veut dire perdre un petit peu en
hauteur et en bas mais vous n'allez pas
perdre d'informations sur le côté donc
ça c'est vachement bien
et puis après la nuance des couleurs
standard chaude aulas mêmes froidevaux
froide c'est pas terrible une fois plus
le standard ça me va bien et après si
vous le souhaitez vous pouvez aller
beaucoup plus loin dans vos paramètres
au travers de ce menu là il est un petit
peu moins sexy mais on peut le faire si
on veut il n'y a rien de bien tordues
ici rien de bien compliqué tout est
sympa c'est vraiment l'idée de la
simplicité
la télécommande est simple les menus
sont sans tyson c'est une des meilleures
expériences
j'irai pour la télé connectée moi j'aime
beaucoup en tout cas et puis ensuite
vous avez le choix de vos sources et
c'est là qu'auront dans une autre
dimension
là vous arriver davantage dans l' usage
professionnel à l'aclu hdmi g vous le
montrer dans quelques instants il ya
plusieurs possibilités pour bien se
connecter moyens truc qui m'intéresse
bien c'est le remote access alors le
remote access on peut l'utiliser
différentes manières ça vous pouvez
connecter un pc distant sans fil sans
problème soit faire un petit partage
d'écran bien évidemment il vous faut ici
un windows 10 vous allez pouvoir venir
partager votre écran directement sans
fil on peut le faire si on souhaite vous
avez le samsung d'aix bien évidemment
vous avez un smartphone samsung ou une
tablette samsung et bien pourrait venir
grâce au texte sans fil
utilisez votre moniteur comme d'un
bolide à un ordinateur c'est intégrer
directement c'est normal de samsung à
samsung
tous fonctionnent ensemble et ça c'est
bien et après vous avez également office
365 il faut un abonnement office 365
mais moi c'est mon cas donc vous
connecter à votre compte microsoft grâce
à office 365 et là vous arrivez
directement dans votre espace de travail
de office 365 bien évidemment vous avez
worn vous avez excellent mais l'idée
c'est que pour trouver tous ici vous
avez votre tableur vous avez vos
informations vous pouvez venir ouvrir
par exemple un calendrier faire vos
factures enfin le faites ce que vous
voulez c'est vraiment très très pratique
et une fois de plus on est dans l'usagé
professionnel et vous avez ce côté là
qui est super intéressant pour venir
vous connecter à office alors le point
un peu négatif est un peu en dessous
c'est que vous utilisez votre
télécommande pour venir naviguer ça
c'est pas très pratique ça peut être
bien pour revoir un truc rapidement
pourquoi pas mais pour venir l'éditer il
vous faut une solution la meilleure
solution pour moi c'est le pc connecté à
distance directement ou alors le samsung
d'aix qui marche bien et qui est une
solution qui est extrêmement cool on
peut le faire avec la télécommande mais
c'est pas là où l'usagé avec le plus
sexy le plus intéressant et après vous
pouvez aller encore plus loin
prenez votre mac et moi c'est ce que je
vais faire et qu'il va aussi matérielle
c'est l' usage professionnel qui a un
sens pour moi grâce à apple airplay et
bien regardez hop je me connecte
directement il va me demander le code au
plat voilà qui est ici je tape mon pti
code
ça me fait donc un vrai mirroring de la
même manière que je pourrai le faire
directement avec mon iphone c'est un
héros ri quand j'ai une petite latence
amène évidemment parce que je suis en
mai rhône je suis connecté sans fil donc
j'ai une petite latence et si je veux
éviter justement ne pas avoir cette
petite latence et bien j'ai une autre
solution qui va vraiment devenir
intéressant ici franges en d2 en réalité
convient me connecter dit
comment on usb c'est derrière d'autant
plus que j'ai de la charge sur le modèle
de m celle que j'ai de la charge sur
l'autre modèle j'ai pas de charge
j'ai de la charge 65 watts dont je peux
venir en même temps chargé mon macbook
pro dont ça c'est cool
et si je peux pas m'embêter avec ça et
bien regardez devenir no branché en hdmi
alors le problème sur les macbook pro
c'est combien branché en hdmi maintenant
eh bien j'ai pas de port hdmi donc
j'utilise un petit meuble donc moi j'ai
tout là-dessus j'ai tous mes disques
durs et moyens c'est un peu le bazar
mais je vais vous le montrer comme ça
vous allez voir c'est pashmul donc je
branche
moi je les ai mis directement sur mon
job et je me branche de l'autre côté up
en usb c'est ce que je vais faire c'est
que je vais justement ici je vais dans
source
je vais dans hdmi par là je retrouve mon
bac et ça c'est vachement cool et vous
pouvez également connecter votre
ordinateur notamment votre macbook ici
mon macbook pro en usb c'est pour faire
transférer d'adata vous récupérez le
signaler en même temps de recharge est
donc assez pratique il vous faut par
contre un câble qui vous permettent de
le faire de trouver le bon câble
si vous prenez le câble de recharge de
votre téléphone par exemple ça marchera
pas voilà vous faut le bon câble
c'est plus qu'un moniteur c'est un
moniteur intelligent qu'il avait
retrouvé sa place très facilement dans
votre maison si vous n'avez pas une
grande pièce avec d'un côté un espace de
travail dédié de l'autre côté un espace
du travail pour les adultes un espace de
travail pour les enfants et une télé est
bien ici vous avez un tout en un ça vous
servira en même temps d'écran de télé
vous avez molotov tv vous avez tout en
un sens je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant
en plus de ça il ya un switch
intelligent si par exemple vous brancher
d'un côté un pc de la côte et vous
brancher une console si le pc est allumé
il vous switch sur l'âge des miens et si
par exemple c'est la console qui allume
et il vous fait le switch directement
sur le hdmi de pas besoin d'aller dans
les paramètres gratouiller directement
comme ça non c'est automatique et ses
pratiques puis au delà de ça moi ce que
j'aime bien c'est vraiment la finesse
que vous allez avoir
vous avez des bords qui sont extrêmement
fins d'écran qui est très très bien
profilée logoté samsung en va ici enfin
le voilà j'aime bien que ce soit le pied
que ce soit le design la largeur la
profondeur enfin bref on a un produit
qui est esthétique qui est très sympa et
qui globalement trouva très facilement
sa place sur un bureau quelle que soit
sa taille quelle que soit sa profondeur
il ya deux modèles qui existent ici là
c'est le m7 ces grands modèles sa
d'écran 32 pouces 4k usage des 3840 par
2160 pixels et vous avez le m5 qui
existent soit en 27 pouces sont 32
pouces comme ici mais dans les deux cas
en full hd 1920 par 1080 que ce soit le
m7 ou le m5 qui sont dans les deux cas
compatible hd
dix côté connectique vous allez
retrouver ici bien évidemment votre
prise secteur pour me dire est branché
c'est tout à fait normal
on va retrouver ici là juste en dessous
du hdmi à ercé deuxième hdmi ici ça
c'est de l'usbc avec une recharge 65
watts et vous retrouvez également ici
trois ports usb vous avez du hdmi 2.0 et
usb 2.0 et en termes de tarifs ils sont
super intéressant le m5 27 pouces coûte
249 euros en modèles 32 pouces le même
sac là c'est le n71 le l5 32 pouces
coûtera 299 euros tandis que celui là le
n 7 ont 32 pouces et une seule taille
coûte 399 euros autant vous dire que si
vous cherchez une solution tout en un
pour la maison vous posez pas trop de
questions a vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce que cette solution-là pourrez vous
tenter est ce qu un tout-en-un
directement sur un moniteur intègre et
intelligente samsung ça pourrait vous
battez si vous va bien évidemment
voulait bien lien en bas dans la
description à vous de dire ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire quand on
se retrouve très vite on a des goûts ou
bisous des gros coeur pour les soigner
et à très bientôt
tiens